how are you guys doing today we're
awesome man how are you I just want to
say one thing
brother you got to roll with him in the
good times and the bad we at 20 year run
we'll be back don't give up hope really
funny you say this because every
Michelle you don't know this but every
time Mark and I talk uh I start every
interview off talking about Boston
Sports because we're both from Boston oh
wow okay and I and I do have an
individual question about Boston sports
for Mark and here we go well I did I did
find myself rooting for them to lose to
get the good draft pick and of course as
soon as I rooted for them to lose they
won yeah we're on the exact same page so
here's here's my question um do you
think that bill bellich who you know I
love he won all these Super Bowls for us
like what is the threshold for us with
Bill bellich coaching for the Patriots
is there a limit to like an a certain
amount of losing Seasons before we
really have to say it might be time for
you to go or because of how many Super
Bowls he won he has like cart blanch
well I think cart blanch for a while I
think you know it's very premature you
know having a you know an unprecedented
20-some year run uh dominating the
entire league not only the division but
so I I think it's very unfair right now
the scrutiny that he's getting and you
know he's the greatest coach of all time
so let him do his thing if he wants to
win you know three games in the season
or four or five you know he's there's a
method to the madness and who are we to
question what his approach is that's
what I was trying to explain to my wife
as we were watching the game and they
were
winning I was like I I would like to see
them kind of lose and and you know uh
dump the season to get a good draft pick
but he's got a plan in mind and so let
him do his thing he certainly earned it
uh and and I've gotten so much joy from
them winning that I'm okay with with
them not being that great I mean
everybody else is loving to talk
about the Patriots excuse my language
but you know they they've been down for
a long time getting stepped on by the
Patriots so let them enjoy their fun I
agree with you I think that he has
brought so much joy to my life that
whatever he wants to do I'm sort of on
board ah he's the best there's a method
to the
madness uh so I have now some other
questions for both of you since I have a
little extra time uh I'm a fan of both
of your work but there's going to be
people out there who have never seen
anything you've done before so to those
people if they've never seen anything
you've done what's the first thing you'd
like them watching and why for me family
plan yeah this why why you can get to
all the other films that you know we
think are great for different reasons
but there's nothing more needed right
now than a family that a movie that
brings everybody together and that
really is enjoyable for the whole family
you know normally you have a movie that
the parents will tolerate because the
kids want to see it and we go sit
through it or vice versa the kids are
kind of getting pushed to go see
something that the parents want to see
but this is something that I've Just
Seen families and and audiences really
thoroughly enjoyed together and all find
relatable and at a time especially this
holiday season with all the craziness
going on to really just be able to enjoy
themselves and laugh and uh and cut up
and see things that they can you know
identify with in their own personal
lives it's uh it's well needed and then
I give a laundry list of movies to watch
starting out with me and Michelle
Patriot Patriots Day of course we can
start there no that that's a whole
another thing so Michelle again for both
of you but yeah what what's been the
most nervous you've been the night
before filming began for the first day
of
filming oh well Mission Impossible three
for sure for sure yeah that was such a
big that was such a big film for me and
you know it was who directed that one um
J.J Abrams yeah it was just such a big
film um I came I just gotten married
kind of skipped my honeymoon to start
the film right away and
yeah I wonder we don't remember the
anniversary
now getting some and then I remember
going going to work and um I think I
think maybe um Tom and I had kind of an
intimate scene and of course of course
that was like the
first and I come no no no and then I
come home from work I was so nervous and
my husband was like don't
worry okay like he's like don't worry
you're going to follow his lead you're
going to have a great time it's going to
be wonderful I come home at the end of
the day open up the hotel room he said
how was it I was like oh my God it was
amazing he was so nice it was great he
goes how cool is it that you were making
out with Tom Cruise on our honeymoon
like cuz we're just such fans like in
that's
what the heck but it's sweet this day
has changed a lot for
me he's learning things oh my he's
learning things but that is a testament
to the man that I married which has just
been totally supportive and is excited
and Jazz for the opportunities no than
no he was just so proud kind of proud
you know I I worked hard to get that
role and it was just one of those things
we just got married and really
discovered our careers in New York
together and so um that was really
special but I was very nervous of course
the night before and then wound up you
know proceeded to have just an amazing
shoot with JJ and Tom and have all the
respect for them in that franchise and
so I I can't believe I shared that story
but it's the truth
um and you what was the most nervous
you've ever met I'm really curious
because that's such a good question
right now
um no uh I think every day the first day
you know um obviously some movies more
than others but working with a new
filmmaker new
people um you know but always kind of
that excitement I always have I'll have
the the dream where you know I forgot
the lines I don't have my script
nobody's there with my pages that sort
of thing but you know as soon as you get
that first shot done it's done it's
always like okay let's go as soon as you
get the first shot in the can but yeah
it's it's exciting when that wears off
or that feeling like wow we did
something really cool today wears off I
don't know I might want to find
something else yeah agreed agreed I love
those nerves so of all the things that I
expected to see in the family plan the
one thing I did not expect to see was
Mark singing Vanilla Ice came completely
out of left field because you've made a
lot of movies I don't remember the last
time you sang in a movie yeah um I ifor
I've had to do it a couple
times don't don't like it but well I'm
just curious was it was it tough to to
sell you on singing Vanilla Ice the
family as well or you just the two of
you I should say or was it one of these
things let's just go for it at that
point it was like let's just go for it
yeah absolutely Simon had sent I think I
don't know a dozen songs whatever the
number was some of them were like random
like Irish folk songs and you know want
to have a bunch of different options I
think the only one that we both knew was
was I I baby so it was like it was the
obvious choice and it was fun you know
it was fun but I think yeah one of the
things about this film um and you sort
of touched on it a little bit is that it
has something for everyone in terms of
the kids actually have storylines you
guys have storylines and so I do think
for families who want to watch something
together uh everyone's going to get
something out of it can you sort of talk
about that and U maybe if that's what
pulled you in to do this yeah all the
roles are very well written well-rounded
characters and um you know people whe
yeah whether they have kids or not it's
it's just very enjoyable from start to
finish you know it's uh filled with
laughs action and uh lots of unexpected
things as as as you just referred to one
of them um so you know that was that was
exciting for me and and and you know um
I got that that gut feeling when I read
the script and then of course seeing the
movie for the first time I was watching
it in my home in the living room I
turned it on and I I knew it was you
know it's a PG-13 movie so I didn't have
to worry about anybody in the house
seeing something that was inappropriate
and you know by the time I started
watching it I started by myself you know
the whole family was sitting around the
living room watching including my
father-in-law and nobody reacted to
anything other than laughing until you
know this one spits the the toothbrush
out of her mouth and then I got the the
you know the look from everybody I
hadn't I hadn't you know warned them
about that particular scene but yeah I
think it's a great I think it's just a
great film that everybody can relate to
you know it's like you you see all of
the you know the teenagers and you the
moms and dads sort of you know trying to
navigate life you know there it's that
evolution of family right and trying to
stay connected and they're all kind of
just going about their own ways and and
I think that they're all just looking to
kind of latch on to each other and so
you just see this this family over the
course of the film start to reconnect
and believe in one another and and
communicate and listen and uh and it's
just really hope and I think I think
families are going to really relate to
it um all the themes and and really have
a lot of fun watching it you both done
uh action in your career you both did
action in this movie um when you think
about everything you've done what's the
sequence or scene that you really can't
believe you did or are you just
exceptionally proud of I learned how to
drive an 18-wheeler I got my class a
driver's license for a film called
trucker and I drove an 18-wheeler up and
down the 10 in the grape vine and I
still can't believe I did that for a
film I can't even drive a a stick shift
but I can drive like a 12-speed with a
splitter with a double clutch and the
you know yeah I'm very impressed
honestly yeah I thought I had something
impressive to say but
I just keep my little humble
accomplishments to
myself but you've done you've done some
cool ass Mark I mean like what's
what's a sequence that you're especially
proud of you know I don't know I
obviously it's 50 something films in
I've done quite a bit of different
things but I think anytime bringing true
stories to the big screen whether it be
or playing a professional athlete and
you know uh or you know bringing you
know the the brave men and women of
operation Redwing to the screen or
father to those are the things that
always I'm always the proud of stuff
Mark individual question for you I've
asked you this I think for like 17 years
will I ever see you in the $6 billion
doll man you know what I think there is
finally hope for that to happen and I
think it's kind of uh actually to a lot
to do with this movie because hopefully
Sky Dan will have the rights if not
fully buttoned up now very soon and uh
and we'll FastTrack that movie to get
made so wow still not out of the fight
I'm still grinding every day to get it
made um you know it's uh it's tough to
get get certain things made it's very
difficult it's always an uphill battle
but I think certain ones are worth just
uh seeing through till the end listen to
me that's a no-brainer movie has it been
a rights issue or has it been just a
like it well it is now I mean we had the
rights and we were trying to get the
script right at Warners and then you
know uh people have the TV rights you
have the estate and then you have I
think Universal had the international
and lots of things so now to kind of
bring it out uh free and clear here to
be able to kind of work out all those
different issues and then uh be able to
start fresh with uh with a new writer um
at Sky dance but I'm excited because
nobody does Action better than uh David
and everybody and Dana and those guys at
Sky dance so couldn't be more excited
about the possibility yeah the one thing
I I David Ellison is I've spoken to him
a number of times he really loves movies
really does he does yeah you
know Michelle individual question for
you uh what can you tease about your
role in Maxine uh because that's one I'm
very very excited for and also there's
another Apple series you're in an apple
series Bad Monkey which I'm also curious
about yeah so I'm I gosh I don't know
how much I can say about Maxine because
let's put it out G to be very caught me
at the end of the day I have to be
careful you know listen I can tell you
we've got an extraordinary cast you know
uh Tai has now um you know we see we see
Maxine now in a different decade uh so
you know it's it's the third it's the
third installment of the franchise and
so we see Mia goth she's incredible um
co-lead is Kevin Bacon and uh I'm
co-starring with Bobby kaval Elizabeth
dicki Lily Collins uh Moses suby we've
got an amazing cast and uh I we shot it
in LA so that gives you a sense of where
it is where it's set and uh it's it's
really an exciting uh film I'm so proud
of I've been a fan of his his work as a
filmmaker for a long time and obviously
I love a24 so really excited to to have
a project with them and Bad Monkey I'm
really excited to share this with
everybody uh it's Bill Lawrence so we
kind of know his brand of Comedy but
Vince vongh is kind of back on on screen
doing what he does best um and I am a
firecracker of a character someone I
haven't played any I have not played a
character like this whatsoever uh in my
life so I'm really excited about her and
we've got an amazing cast jod Turner
Smith Rob delini um uh it's just a
wonderful wonderful Ensemble and I think
that'll probably be coming out in late
spring maybe early summer set in Miami
and it's based on Carl heis book of
course is who's an amazing writer on
that note I need to stop I'm just going
to say seriously uh thank you for giving
me your time and indulging in my uh in
my you know Patriots questions etc etc
all good brother good to see
you